welcome back to las vegas now we're
almost done with summer which means
we've got to get ready for those colder
fall and winter days
lifestyle expert sema cohen is sharing
some pre-fall health essentials for the
whole family let's check it out
hey everybody it's great to be back on
las vegas now
and i'm here to present my free fall
care essentials
for the whole family first up
we have skin tea skin tea is the first
ever collagen sparkling tea and the
company was founded by three
women i love that as the weather start
to change
this is a great way to boost our immune
system
skinty's formula is made with brewed
organic tea
and super herbs each one of them comes
with
three thousand milligrams of collagen
antioxidants
and one hundred percent of your daily
vitamin c
they come in three refreshing flavors
and their paleo
low calorie and gluten free great
and safe for the whole family all right
next
do we have any chef inspired cook out
there
this one is just for you sadaf sadaf is
a family-owned company that's been
around for over 30 years
they take pride in making products that
are natural
wholesome and as close to homemade as
possible
i love that they carry wide variety of
kitchen and pantry items
that you absolutely can't find anywhere
else
and even better than that they ship
nationwide what i chose for us today
is the line of soups homemade soups all
you have to do
is add water heat and voila done
another thing that i absolutely love is
the pure saffron thread
it's also known as the red gold if
you're a cook you know what i'm talking
about
they also have their tuna saffron spray
and thousands of idle items great
company
great product perfect for this season
all right
tonic tonic is a woman owned an operated
cbd
company they use plant-based ingredients
to provide a more balanced targeted and
effective
wellness solution for our mind body and
soul
all of the products are lab tested and
verified at three
different points to ensure quality
purity and consistency
what i love here check this out they
have two lines the first one is for us
the
oils and the second one for our pets
how about that this is great all right
last but not least myra swim this
company was founded in brisbane
australia
it's a luxury whale brand focused on
efforts of
sustainability this line is not just a
swimmer
it's an everyday wear and resort wear
that you can wear
all year round this is a perfect example
of a swim
top swimwear top that you can wear as a
top with your denim with jeans with
everything i love that this line is
adored by
celebrities such as jlo kylie jenner
courtney kardashian and many many more
stay warm and stay healthy this pray
fall season